we have our next
presenter WJ I'm sorry Justin
seon he is a
nutritionist beef nutrition extensionist
at mu and he's coming to you to talk
about gracing W use in beef production
systems please welcome
Justin move that out of the
way good
morning and and so the uh the title of
my talk is related to grazing wed use
and beef production systems and and the
primary reason that it is related to
beef is because that's what I do but it
certainly is applicable to multiple
species of livestock and and we'll talk
a bit about that uh as we go forward and
and so just I guess a kind of the way to
start is what is a grazing wedge and and
so the grazing wedge is a concept that
was uh kind of started in the grazing
dairies specifically in the in the
southwestern part of of Missouri where
we look at our forage inventory in a
visual system and and so the grazing
wedge kind of what I would say is simply
explained is that this is a visual
illustration of a collection of pastures
and so I I use this as an illustration
and and maybe it's not a great one
because you might be looking to say 58
pastures this is way more than I need to
to kind of think about but but just stay
with me and I'll show you some more uh
applied examples here in a minute but
function what the grazing wedge does is
we go out and we inventory our forage
with something as simple as a yard stick
or as complex as a sonar reader on the
front of a four-wheeler and and so from
a technology standpoint you can use a
yard stick or a grazing stick in this
case you can use a rising plate meter uh
either digital or manual or you can get
a sonar amounted uh deal for the front
of your um four-wheeler and and Dr Colin
Bach one of my colleagues is is actually
working on being able to take pictures
using Google Earth to take forage
inventory and and so the technology is
uh fairly diverse I guess is the way I
would say it but the grazing wedge gives
us a visual picture of our forage
inventory and and so it's it's kind of a
um u a stoplight system in that once our
our pasture in this case turns red we've
gotten to the point where that pasture
from a quality standpoint is too mature
and if we keep our pasture gure in the
green area then we have optimized forage
quality and then when we get it into the
yellow that is the point where we have
overgrazed it and that's based off of
measurements that we're taking as
infrequently as uh once a month ideally
what we would like to see is about every
10 to 14 days and so a bit of background
as it relates to this program is it it's
part of a sustainable agriculture
research and education grant research
and educ ation specifically and we have
producer Cooperators that collected a
lot of this data and we've we've
developed these producer groups that are
centered around these producers that use
their forage growth data as kind of
indicator values throughout the grazing
season I'll show you that in a minute
okay and so the the idea behind the the
grazing wedge is OB objective pasture
Management in that many people have
implemented rotational grazing systems
but many times we rotate through those
systems systems in a pattern that maybe
is convenient but not best from a forage
management standpoint do we always start
with south facing slopes in the early in
the season or do we start with the one
that's closest to the barn and so this
allows us to look at pasture from a
standpoint of growth and seasonal growth
and try to best utilize it we measure
and monitor that over the uh over the
the entire pure season but really what
we found through this work with the with
the producers is that first pass through
the past sets it for the rest of the
year if you do a good job of pasture
Management in May the rest of the year
is very easy or specifically late April
I should say but uh once once that
reproductive plant portion has been
taken off at the beginning the pasture
is kind of set for the rest of the year
and so if you want to think about that
from an applied standpoint what's the
best pasture that you'll see all year
long it was largely cut as hay right
uniformly grazed in theory and and so
that regrowth we don't have any stems or
or reproductive tillers that we see
later on in the season so how do we set
up a management system that addresses
that goal at the end the other thing is
it helps us to address which forage
should we use next and and this I
apologize doesn't show up real well with
the amount of light but but one of the
things to think about is if you go
through and and graze a system and and
let's say you have an eight pasture
system right and and so you've set up
some sort of grazing system early in the
spring you'll go through and and graze a
pasture and and about miday it looks
really good right it looks really good
it's been nothing but regrowth and then
you have some pasture that looks similar
to this over here where you start to see
reproductive uh or seed heads start to
produce and and so you say well I need
to go graze this because I haven't been
there yet right that's that's the next
pasture to go to and I haven't been
there yet but in reality what I want we
used the grazing wedge just to challenge
producers to stay this is the part of
the farm that we should be making hay on
because it's already too mature for the
growing stock that we have in place and
this is ideal in terms of forage quality
and once forage goes bad or gets mature
goes to the red part on the grazing
wedge it's already
mature it'll take the cattle longer to
get through this more mature material
and in the end this stuff starts to get
overgrown and so from a management
standpoint that's part of the question
that we try to address with a grazing
wedge and so when we started this is uh
Denny and Mary Beth poges grazing wedge
that uh we started in 2010 and this was
uh the 23rd of May and this is kind of
the visual image that when you when you
take those forage quality measurement or
those forage inventory measurements you
get a visual display of your pasture and
so these are each of their pastures that
are labeled and and so what we see in a
lot of beef Enterprise systems is we we
start to push a lot of forage ahead into
the summer right and and so beef systems
are inherently more tolerant of poorer
quality forage the biggest question that
we get from beef producers is I need
more forage it's not forage quality that
we run out of I need more forage this
year probably more so than ever and so
the Dare or the grazing wedge was
actually started in the dairy system and
the dairy system they're highly aware of
forage quality and so one of the things
that we set out to do was just try to
see how this worked with a beef
production model and one of the first
things that we observed was that we see
a lot of our beef producers maintain a
lot more forage specifically at this
3500 lbs and of uh of growth more so
than our Dairy who much like it to be
under 3,000 lb more about
2750 and and so to think to put that in
a practical term you want forage in a
beef production system to be about this
the height of the eyeball on the cow
that's when her head's down right when
her head is down eyeball high is a good
forage availability and quality uh
guideline and if you can see her nose
when her head is down you're in this
yellow portion over here at overg grazed
okay uh good Lord put a grazing stick on
every cow between the eyeball in the
nose Jim garish is actually credited
with that concept but we're trying to
put that on a visual perspective
from a standpoint of how we can
inventory our pastures and so the
critical points in a grazing wedge this
is the the 4 Farms grazing wedge on in
the towards the end of June this year
and what we want to do from a fertilizer
and management standpoint is ideally we
have a pasture that's being staged right
along right when we get to the point
where our pastures are all flat we we
have a forid shortage coming and so this
visual illustration that we we send out
to these producers producers every two
weeks or the producers submit every two
weeks tells them that when they get to
pasture 5 on a 21-day rotation if it
falls below this line you need to start
thinking about some sort of forage
management system to meet the deficiency
right and so this year it was great to
kind of look at we started it wasn't
great I'm I'm not glad we had a drought
okay but it Illustrated the
appropriateness of this where we start
to
see we start to see these uh pasture
levels turning flat and we can start to
make management decisions before hey
prices get to $100 a ton and so it helps
us from an inventory management
standpoint and what we want to do is
maintain forage quality here and make
sure we don't overg graze it on the
other end and so that's what we call the
critical points as we think about
interpreting the grazing wedge here's
kind of how you can think about this is
that when it's underneath the line I'm
setting myself up for a forage
deficiency going forward right if I can
keep it above the line I've got enough
forage that it's right at the eyeball
high of the cow and this 1500 Line This
is like thinking about how many bales of
hay you have functionally in that I can
graze it down to 1500 lb of dry matter
and everything above it is forage on the
stump and so it allows us to start
calculating how much forage we have I
visited with our livestock specialist
this morning and this is something that
going to go out and do right now this is
the ideal time to go out and measure
your forage CU it's not going to grow
anymore the amount of forage that you
have right now is what you're going to
have available and so I can calculate
how many days of forage I have out there
and start to uh balance my
supplementation needs going forward
whether that's a supplement or hay
fundamental concept as it relates to the
grazing wedge is let's graze at to 1,400
lb of dry matter per acre on the first
pass okay and and so that is a very
tight system it it is extremely tight
from a from a 4 height standpoint but
that sets our pasture up just like
running a hay Bine across that field and
and the regrowth is going to be
vegetative for the rest of the summer
okay one of the things that we really
struggle with is we have non-uniform
grazing equals nonuniform regrowth and
you've observed this out in the past
years I I um I would assume is that
around manure piles or urine spots we
see this tall forage that those cattle
never come back to and it's not because
it's the manure pile per se but late in
the season this is mature and they've
got other vegetative forage to eat the
rest of the year and so we want those
cattle to be very aggressive the first
pass through when the forage is very
good and the manure piles are generally
fairly loose and then we set up the
season or set it up uh for the rest of
the season this is some of the forage
quality that we've observed in these
grazing wedge systems and so I I like to
show this line This is crude protein and
the crude protein requirement of the
beef cows right about here okay and so
in terms of protein content management
under this system provides more than
adequate protein to those cows but maybe
more importantly what we looked at is
what is the fiber content of that forage
and so from a from a productive
standpoint what I want you to think
about is a high bar on this chart is bad
okay a high bar is fiber and fiber is is
not highly digestible and a low bar here
is indigestibility
so the best way to illustrate this is
what we observed is something that we
we've uh told producers for a long time
is if you want to maximize the Harvest
of indigestible forage make your hay in
July and the forage samples that we took
under this system certify that is that
the forage is not as digestible in July
and August and we produce a high amount
of fiber so F
Focus excess forage harvest in April May
and June and because we've used the
grazing wedge we know what our forage
inventory is going forward as well as a
from a growth rate standpoint and and so
from a second pass forage standpoint we
think about how can we best utilize the
forage if I say I want you to graze it
to 3 in tall and you say that's pretty
poor quality forage for a lactating cow
and so what we want you to think about
is well is there some replacement heers
that could utilize that poor quality
forage is there some dry cows that could
utilize this poor quality forage to get
it down to that, 1400 lb of dry
matter and so I I like to show pictures
of these are the groups of cattle or
livestock that most people have standing
around we have some late gestation
cattle we have some early lactation
cattle we have some cattle that are
ready to be weaned and then we have a
group of growing cattle or replacement
heers and if you think about not a
prioritization standpoint and that how
do we match our forage grazing wedge to
our cattle is that something that is
pregnant and getting ready to Cal or
lamb or kid whatever it is they have
first priority of forage they get the
first bite okay after that it's the
lactating animal because if she doesn't
have adequate condition at cing you'll
never add condition to her unless you
start carrying a feed bucket and so we
we educated our producers such that we
want these cows to get the green forest
and then if we have some red Forge that
we're not going to bail these are the
type of cattle that we want to use that
on because they have lower nutrient
requirements so as you prioritize
gestating cataler first early lactation
cater second and these two groups are
fairly flexible depending on your
production goals and and so that was
part of our educational component was
matching it to the uh Forge
Supply I like to show this in that if
you bush hog pastures during the month
of July that's not a product of the
month of July it's a product of forage
Management in April and May and that if
if you're if you're cleaning up pastures
in in uh May or in July sorry many times
what has happened is that pasture got
away from you in May and and if we can
graze it appropriately April and May
really focus our forage management
efforts using these tools it it
minimizes the amount of fuel and time
that we have to spend cleaning up uh
raising mistak so to speak the other
thing that this uh system allows us to
do and and I realize of one of the as a
producer no one likes keeping records
okay that's like the the number 20th
thing that people like to do and so by
entering these yield numbers you can
actually determine we actually determine
in the grazing wedge what the pasture
yielded in grazable forage we look at it
over time in terms of forage
disappearance and so this is um Denny
Po's pasture 2012 they've harvested
anywhere from 2 to 3 tons per acre off
of those pastures and that's based off
of forage measurements that he's taken
throughout the season every 14 to 21
days and that allows us to see that 5B
and 4C are are maybe not as productive
as 10e and so if I have to prioritize my
fertilizer or I'm going to apply manure
or something along those lines
these are the two pastures that are
perhaps most in need or I know that
there's more water holding capacity
maybe in 10e maybe that's in the bottom
and so I'm going to put a higher level
of nitrogen there because I know I get a
response and so this allows us to look
at our pastures objectively and see
actually which pastures green up earlier
in the spring as well without keeping
records just as an inventory management
standpoint okay and uh this may be a
little small for those of VI in the back
but at the end of the year we also print
out a summary report and and so this is
he uh has started taking uh taken
measurements the 31st of March and took
them all the way up to the 20th of
October and this is 2012 and this is
estimated growth rate and so one of the
things I like to visit with producers
that we've shown from this data is we'll
grow three cows worth of feet a day the
end of April and early May on one acre
of ground and that the amount of feed
that comes out early April and or late
April and early may we can't stock for
that there's no way we can stock to
consume that amount of forage in a short
period of time and so what we look at as
we get down here into June and July
we're growing four pounds of feed per
acre per day okay and that's not a
surprise but normally we would see this
in the 25 to 30 lb range but this was
2012 and so it allows us to go back and
say what was our pre grazing and
postgrazing cover and and what hases
that done to the long-term growth rate
or or pasture
health and can we maintain an average
pasture cover around 2,300 lb and so
it's a it's a recordkeeping system that
is a product of an inventory management
if we take those measurements this is
all generated for you and you can look
at your grazing season at uh at the end
of the year and see what kind of growth
rates you you received on each of these
pastures and and the other thing that
kind of indicates is what we call the
key indicators and and this is where
each of these producers who are kind of
what I call our Sentinel producers
they're posted on the internet you can
look and I've shown the website several
times but you can see where they're at
relative to the state and what's going
on and so in this case we see that we've
got beef stalker cattle on the pasture
the forage growth rates about 12 pounds
an acre per day
and those stalker cattle are being fed 7
and 3/4 of a pound of uh of grain or a
pound of hay sorry and critical issues
they make notes and so you can kind of
see what's going on throughout the state
and this one's weed control is working
well one and A4 inches of rain yesterday
total rain since the end of April 1.75
in and so the producers are commenting
on what they're seeing locally and
allows us to kind of use those as a as a
as a guideline to what's going going out
going on out in the state and as you
find it if if you're interested in
joining these groups it allows people to
kind of say here's an indicator may not
be current for me but it allows me to
know what's going on relative to other
locations this is the the one uh example
that I think probably has the most value
that we learn through working with
producers is the fall inventory and that
there's nothing worse than realizing
that you don't have enough hay about the
middle of February because there's not a
lot of hay being produced in the middle
of February and everybody else has
realized that same thing at about that
time and so from a cost standpoint as we
went through the financial analysis of
these operations is that how can I
predict the amount of grazing days that
I've got before I'm going to have to
feed hay and then how much of that hay
am I going to use kind of going forward
and and so this is just a label of a
bunch of pastures and this is the amount
of dry matter that's available on the
stump and and and so this is the amount
of forage this is the amount of acres in
each of those paddocks and then it
calculates tons of feed available in
each of those pastures and so you take
how many cows you've got and how many
tons of feed and then you can look at
your hay Supply and match our forage
availability with our intake hopefully
such that you get to the point where as
an inventory management tool inventory
is one of the biggest challenges we face
is that I don't want to spend more money
than I have to because it's tied up in
the hay right all year long until I need
it again but I certainly don't want to
have to pay two times for the hay
because I ran short at the worst
possible time of year and so we use this
fall inventory in that as as something I
would have you take home today is if
you're not interested in the grazing
wedge at all throughout the growing
season the fall inventory component is
as useful as anything to plan your
winter feed needs
and and so our feed and forage budgeting
is essentially our stocking rate which
is pounds of cattle times a percent body
weight intake and then the utilization
rate is what percentage your forage is
used and during the growing season we're
hoping that that's going to be somewhere
in the 50 to 70% range in the dormant
season it's a lot closer to 70% because
they're going to they're going to
utilize that we don't get a lot of
regrowth and then how long can I graze
you know if you if you think you've got
60 days of stockpile forage on hand that
tells you you know about when you're
going to start feeding hay and and it
just allows you to better manage your
inventory and if you know that you have
60 days of stockpiled forage and I've
shown you kind of what the quality
results are under that management system
we're encouraging producers to think
about that stockpile as a supplement as
opposed to a um total diet intake and
and so I explained that a bit in that
people don't like buying feed many times
but what we haven't thought about
stockpile is as supplemental feed I'm
going to put hay out but I'm going to
strip graze a certain amount of forage
so that that is the supplemental feed
and and I can strip graze that because
one of the first things that the
producers will tell me as it relates to
stockpiles like Justin if I had 70 more
acres to stockpile I'd have more cows
and that's a that's a valid statement
but what I encourage people to do from
an inventory standpoint is let's think
about stockpiling some forage or even
just using our fall growth most
effectively by saying you know what I'm
going to strip graze this off as a
supplement I'm going to give you three
days worth of supplemental grass and it
it supplements our poor quality forage
so the the biggest thing I wanted you to
take away with is the grazing wedge
gives you an opportunity to look at how
you manage your grats from an inventory
standpoint what we've kind of found
through our visiting with producers is
they do this for about two maybe 3 years
and after that they get a pretty visual
assessment of that system and they don't
go out and maybe measure as much as they
would normally but they'll go out and do
that one measurement in the fall and and
so it's kind of a growing process to
learn how the forage quality is best
managed relative to yield so with that
I'll uh take any questions yes
sir may sorry we have
to you talked about
um mowing the pasture in in May
um could you hold off till June and bail
it
up you where you say it gets away from
you could
you so so relative to forage management
one of the things that we we look for is
that we're all trying to capture as much
Sunshine as we can right our goal is to
capture Sunshine we have soil and we
have a photosynthetic leaf and how do we
capture sunshine and so one of the
challenges with letting that fore grow
and get further mature is it starts to
shade itself right and so if you think
about where does grass not grow well
under trees and so when it sends up a
reproductive tiller or seed head it
starts to shade the lower leaves and and
the Dairy Producers have have gone to
that uh three leaf grazing system
there's only three live leaves on a
Fescue plant the fourth one starts to
die I will answer your question I'm just
going through some background okay and
and so one of the things we want to do
is the sooner we can stop reproductive
growth in that it shoots up one
reproductive tiller okay one seed head
and once that's cut off everything else
is regrowth right and regrowth is our
quality and so we're very aggressive at
addressing that early on so that the
sooner that we Harvest it the sooner it
can start regrowing we have more
moisture and cooler temperatures if we
wait until June to go in and and take
that closer then what we have is we
don't have a lot of water available for
rapid recovery and it's hotter when you
mow pasture in the spring okay if you go
in and hay pasture in the spring early
in the spring like within 2 days it's
it'll have a leaf out there like that
youve when you get it off there you see
that leaf that sticks out it's very
quick in terms of its regrowth what
we're trying to avoid is the shading as
much as anything and that as it gets go
ahead yeah
so baage is their best option or or
stock such that so one of the you know
there's a there are a number of people
that are what I call Hay haters right
they think hay is the bane of of a
pasture system and so one of the things
we think about is on a fall caving
system we keep those cavves around to
help us manage that excess inventory of
forage and then we sell those calves in
June and and that relieves the amount of
stocking rate such that a cows can go
through the summer that's one option if
you can't make hay in May what i bage is
our best option and where we can make it
wet think they bags anym you got buy one
of bagging Mach yeah got to have a
wrapper
yeah no you can not you might try that
but it won't be very
successful well and and and so from
a yeah those are hard to try do that as
well but that's where you know maybe
it's even a custom deal or manage your
stocking rate stocking rate being the
big one in that how do I match the
forage that I have and most people you
know stocking rate is the number one
factor influencing the success of of a
pasture system is that do you stack for
2012 stack stock for 2012 or do you
stock for 2008 one of the wetest years
that we've had and and the question is
is it it depends and so how do I build
flexibility into that system and what we
found is many producers don't know how
much forage they they can grow under a
management system this gives us the
opportunity to look at that as a uh
forage growth rate and then we can start
to put an animal system on it that's
well
matched uh grazing beef missouri.edu
n